number one you asked to find the
equations of the director see so you can
see the way I did it you really need to
get the right color you really needed to
get your equation in a form that made a
and B clear and I that and that allowed
you off of the coordinates of the foci
to find what the eccentricity was and
once you've got that it was pretty
elementary to get the right equations
that was that number two that was just
recognition of that simple result so you
use the reference sheet just a flag on
the reference sheet some questions some
integrals that were on the reference
sheet we list and like you just lost
marks on really simple things so if it's
an integral right we know that four
sections like conex for which would be
lovely to have stuff on the reference
yet we don't have but sony integrals
that are there upon the extension one
course so they're on the reference sheet
so when you're doing the HC exam if your
dad about any of those please go back it
doesn't take you long just to confirm
when you're checking for your answers
yeah
that's correct you will not get the
table of Santa Jules you will get the
reference sheet which has all of the
integrals in a bar to that were actually
never in the syllabus anyway and so if
you have to use any of those results
it'll be part of the question to do that
okay okay I number three that was a
pretty simple implicit differentiation
question so you pretty much nailed that
or you did it part for a straightforward
use of two things number one identify
what the compliment is and secondly
using tomorrow's theorem so that was ok
now another five let's all have a look
at this one together because it came to
bite us back in question 12 so I want to
dwell it for a second they give you a
graph and then you're also look at all
of these foreign identify which the
reciprocal is okay so what I've done is
I've written down this is how I know
which one the reciprocal is what can you
tell about a reciprocal function okay
number one if you've got zeros then when
you take the reciprocal of that you're
in trouble you get asymptotes so that's
why I've said they're discontinued it is
secondly if you have a positive number
you take its reciprocal it's still
positive and it's the same for a
negative so if you have a look at where
it's positive and negative for your
original function the reciprocal should
preserve those and then largely lastly
about the the magnitudes of things once
you put all three of those together the
only option that fits all of those is a
okay I'm you could have kind of for
example you ever you look at your for
answers there your options you can
immediately ignore B&D right which I
know a lot of you saw oh yeah that's
silly there are no asymptotes on those
so that it's just a matter of looking at
science number six a simple one I will
pause on this not because this question
was done badly but because polynomial
was done badly admittedly I think as a
sort of overall course thing a lot of
the time we sort of it don't put much
time on to polynomial or inequalities
because it doesn't fit into all the
calculus stuff that we learn and it's
sort of a bit on the side this question
and the other ones that had to do with
polymers we did quite poorly yet so this
is the process you've got that
polynomial which has alpha beta and
gamma rays its roots if you want to an
alpha to beta 2 1 go
instead that you can see substituting
whoopsie-daisy subject in two on X into
your arm into the polynomial already
been provided that will transform
everything so you have the roots that
you want ok and then it's some simple
algebra number eight that was a simple
one in fact it was testing much the same
skill so you had to work out your
eccentricity number nine ok so the
volumes now I think again just to
identify volumes was not done well iya
as an overall thing admittedly it's it's
probably a fair bit of work for you know
one mark I have pointed out and i hope
what if you know in all of your exam
exams one to ten or not the easiest ten
marks in the paper question 11 is the
easiest 15 marks in the paper questions
1 to 10 you'll get questions you'll
totally get questions like this it's
heaps of work that has to be applied so
maybe you look at this thing ok I'll
come back to it and then maybe at least
guess ok but nonetheless here's the
process that you go through you
obviously didn't have to draw such a
beautiful diagram as that but it did
help you wrap your head around what's
the radius what what dimension are we
going through with the thicknesses
they're obviously oriented vertically so
that's why it's Delta Y and this is what
your expression looks like as you go
ahead and you integrate so 2 pi a cubed
where's your number alright so question
this question is for silicon shells
vision because it's a multiple choice is
it that would that be
the reason why they've done it is to try
and just give you a bit of a nudge I
think it is my chili quicker to do it
this way but if you did it by slices
there's no penalty for yeah yeah yeah
yeah you could that's fine and you can
get the results no problem okay but I
the reason why I've shown you the
solution this way is because if it
doesn't appear as a multiple choice
question then you still want to know how
to do it in the prescribed fashion okay
all right last multiple choice let me
just pause here because we'll come back
to this point one of the hardest parts
of integration in extension to is making
sure you're careful with all these crazy
kinds of solutions being careful with
your boundary values or that kind of
thing I think we're a little haphazard
when we're doing this step up here when
we're actually going through okay what
are the things that I'm going to have to
substitute in and if you do that wrong
then of course all this stuff down here
it almost doesn't matter um you will
either number one dramatically simplify
the question which means number one you
have gotten the question wrong and then
you simplified it so you've lost two
marks or alternatively you've turned
into some integral that we don't have
the tools to do and then you're stuck so
all of that just to say please please
please take the time slow down nail that
part and then the rest should fall out
okay and that would be something which I
come back to you later in the paper
which is why I'm mentioning it now all
right ok let's begin then into the
extended response so happy news is that
a lot of questions 11 and 12 were
generally well done so i will sort of
hop through a lot of this fairly rapidly
and please pause me at the end of the
question if you want me to come back to
any particular so here's part a your
classic partial fraction this question
so because it was a classic question
most people encountered it just fine ok
you can page enumerators you gather your
like terms got them as those x squared X
and your constant term and everything
fell out I will just point out could you
just briefly look at the way i set this
out you can see my question has very
well-defined stages okay so it's like
okay at the beginning equate these two
things right and then when you don't
have to worry about the denominators get
the denominator
the way and start to form your
simultaneous equations and show me where
you got these simultaneous equations
from now of course do you have to say
that nor but people who did it or people
who got confused about which equations
which like you just had just imagine
what this would look like if all you had
was this right and and students did if
all you have is this over here it's just
this string of equations which number
one is very easy to mix our and number
two it's not clear how you're going to
get them to interact together because
sometimes you haven't labeled carefully
or you just forget where did I get these
these printables and coefficients from
so I think it's helpful for you to be
clear once you've got those equations
set up solving simultaneously was the
easiest part and the numbers just fell
out okay continuing the only thing that
was worth mentioning here is that many
students for forgot that at the origin
there's no defined argument because if
you're there you like okay which way am
I facing you can't defy it you can't say
oh it's play on two or zero or pie
there's no value of that everyone could
agree on so that's why there's a hollow
circle that it can't be part of the
domain whenever the argument is interest
is related okay but most people were
okay with the rest of it's inside the
circle and you've got the range of
angles just fine